now won't you say we're gonna be here  for you said that I'd be back for our  graduation you should stand our mountain  house I thought you guys were selling I  just have to leave for a bit on Sundays  during open houses it's good to see some  new faces  you must be Logan everybody knows  everybody in these small towns huh  so sorry for what happened to your  husband I lost my husband a few years  back  Seth  it's like it moves in and never leaves  Sam search the entire house there's no  one here we had an open house here a few  days ago maybe someone found a spare key  laying around her maybe someone stayed  probably just some kids trying to scare  the newcomers didn't feel like kids  who's that  hey hey something is clearly going on  hello is anyone there that's always nice  to know you have someone nearby the  quiet out here can get real loud  you  you